hello chubs hello easy question what was
your best prompt what was the best prop
that's a great question Michael was it
your bath
yeah it was my sticky goo in my bald cap
my favorite prop on the show oh you know
what it was a [ __ ] stupid little uh
pyramid balls yeah cuz that game was
impossible to figure out we had no idea
what the game was we made it up on the
day literally made that up that was my
first day of shooting yeah that pyramid
game that game that we play in the show
no rules no idea no nothing our stunt
coordinator goes you know just shoot the
ball around I was like what does that
mean if you play basketball I can shoot
a ball around I've never this game
doesn't exist on paper so he's like and
they're like well we're just gonna film
a master so you guys just you know I
just play on the court or like play what
there's no game so we made all that up
and so I think about that all the time I
love those little miniature I do balls I
like small balls um speaking of small
balls oh sorry
so Jett like every time someone says
small balls I think I got quote from
clueless when she goes my doctor told me
to avoid any sports where balls fly at
my face and she goes well there goes our
social life sorry I I saw a video on
online of you with a beautiful model of
a Viper and you were examining it and
turning it around and yes breaking bits
off it I think yeah did you imagine now
um that was pretty amazing those guys
from quantum some Qantas has something
like that made that it was quite
stunning um my favorite props from both
of my guns
personally it was weird though because
you had I had them on both sides which I
was like totally channeling Angelina
Jolie and I'd actually hit myself in the
wrist when I ran or walked so I always
had bruises on my wrists on both from
both sides of the gun but I loved them I
actually have any heavy pro
like a gun yeah I mean they had the
weight of like a real weapon which we
know about in the States we used to run
BBC science fiction dramas over here
they'd be made of plastic and they fall
apart on the first use right exactly I
was actually shot real like bullets and
they were actually quite cool welcome to
America here's your gun there you go
there's plenty more questions I'm sure
we got one over there in the middle
favorite episode classic question
someone had to ask it thank you sir
she's still figuring out the micro think
I'm drunk
not yet um favorite episodes are the
question um my favorite episode was my
first episode 4 of season 2 because the
men I had a job for the next couple of
years um no I actually if that's a
really hard question it's an almost
impossible to answer so I just think of
things that that stick out of my memory
and for me it was my first episode in
season 2 because I had now in retrospect
looking back I had no idea at that time
what was going to happen with the
character of Anders I was just meant to
be on the show for two episodes I was
hired to fall in love with a girl we
sleep together then she kicks my ass out
of bed that was going to be the end of
Anders that was going to be it and it it
just expanded from there so I always
have a dear place in my heart for that
first episode because I had no idea what
it was going to become and what it would
what it would eventually evolve into so
that's for me is my favorite episode
didn't they just get out of the
emergency room don't remember that yeah
we met my mom was in town I had an ulcer
and I was out of the emergency room and
they let me go and I could only eat
bread for like an entire week and I was
like eating up like bagels yeah sorry um
just catching up just hanging out you
haven't seen him for a while um mine was
unfinished business
I loved the boxing episode and when we
get married and
yeah it's gonna make eyes at each other
oh that's so nice so there you go the
question was if you were in charge and
could take your characters in any
direction what would you have done not
get balls and be stuck in a tub of goo I
would have done something way more
heroic and ass-kicking than sitting in a
bathtub with little hairs floating in
hit-boy man that's such a great question
because I actually I put such faith and
trust into our writers you know who was
obviously led at the top by Ron Moore
but we had such a great staff of writers
from Bradley Weddle and Michael Angelli
and Michael Taylor and all these guys
Jane Espenson that I you know you just
kind of go along for the ride
I don't think for me personally I wasn't
upset with any of the story I mean that
obviously the whole cylon development
was coming way out of left field but you
just ride the wave you know you put your
faith when you have such good riding and
you have such a great creative team you
just put your faith in the process and I
was kind of happy the way it turned out
I kind of liked the ending I liked the
ending to UM you know people always it's
the one question I get asked more than
anything is um you know what was she and
would I've changed that's actually two
questions sorry the two questions and
then you know would I've changed the
ending because it's people are so split
down the middle 50/50 about if they
loved it or hated it and there's really
no like down the you know there's really
no um kind of ambiguity to that answer
it's just people are very
passionate about it and so I don't know
I wouldn't have changed anything I love
the way it ended
the character was totally cray-cray um
which I loved
um so yeah I wouldn't have changed
anything
I don't think Thanks no can we we're
gonna need security just out of
curiosity for this is for both of you
I'm sorry what's your name sir
squelching squelching uh hey listen um
so you had a group list of cast members
that kind of recycled and recurred
through the show and I'm just wondering
from from each of you who was your
favorite recurring guest cast member and
you know take your time with this one
god nobody comes to mind you know it's
funny is um there was this guy once
what guy what was his name he's still
forgetting was the guy in the beginning
that played the old man he's an old man
and then he showed up later he's very
handsome I remember that he was really
old was hurt
that wasn't it telling him an old
enhance okay when the Nev showed up no
nobody comes nobody comes to mind maybe
never say nothing very memorable yeah
there was this Ryan Robbins guy but he
wasn't that good yes no that was not
that guy now he's a head he was one of
our morning figure I wasn't yeah that's
sorry no fans of Ryan Robbins I I don't
I don't want to catch the answer JT in
the room no I don't I don't I don't
think so all right well thanks for
answering my question really good
question no sir it's a really good
question a big fan and I heard Ryan
Robbins is here you can catch him over
at this table yeah I went over there
directly did it go here's gone okay yeah
I was the only one in like it was
playing do you have credentials are you
allowed in the building yeah okay I love
you guys love you too I'm like a
gentleman
Aundre
well they'll have him back in his table
in case you guys missed that Ryan
Robbins actually played two characters
on the show he was the the guy in the
first the armas was at the Armistice
station or something like that yeah
where Tricia like blows him up she
kisses him and then his like sorry Ryan
dressed up like an old man and he was so
good they brought him back for an
entirely different character yeah there
you go anymore for anymore who we got
any more actors that one I should
mention is somebody with arm up over
there every time they hand the
microphone to someone I'm scared hi
thanks for being in the show it was
great um I wanted to ask the show was a
product of its of its time especially
politically and the further the show got
on it had more of a spiritual aspect to
it and I wondered did the content of the
show did it make you really reconsider
how you felt politically and also
spiritually by the end of it you know I
think any time that you question um a
bigger picture in life and things that
are going on around you is probably good
so I think it's the only way you can
figure out how you feel about something
is to be curious you know I am religious
beliefs were I think for me that's
always evolving and changing as I get
older and so the show quite possibly
could have had a hand in that
you know um politically is an
interesting thing as well because I
think that we had you know Mary and
Eddie both have no qualms about talking
about their political beliefs and their
stance on where you know things are
going in our governments in the United
States and and Mary had some scenes and
so did Eddie that they had a really hard
time doing because it's it was so the
opposite of the way that they would feel
politically that they wanted their voice
heard and and they had to kind of let it
go and realize that another character
was gonna you know and that's the cool
thing about the show is that everybody
who had different opinions in the world
and in our country
had someone they could relate to so it
was you know it wasn't like it was just
like religious or government propaganda
it was it was pretty much you know um
everybody was kind of represented and
all beliefs sets were represented which
was a great part of the show and the
smart part of the show you know I was
really really smart for being so tired
ya know that was just gonna expand on
what Katie's saying is that I think Ron
Moore captured the essence of what was
happening globally especially at that
time in a post-911 world particularly in
the United States of America
it was very reflective of the he had a
finger on the pulse of what was
happening politically and socially in
our world and he was making a statement
about war and religion and and belief
and and ideologies all these concepts
that aren't usually associated with the
sci-fi show I think Battlestar Galactica
captured beautifully and it sort of put
the genre in a new light people who were
expecting sci-fi to just be pointy ears
and lasers and a lot of you know special
effects came to our show and found
something much deeper
and I think like Katie said it was
impossible for us as actors not to be
aware of that and to reflect on your own
politics and your own opinion of
religion and your own opinions of
governments and imperialism and society
and it really the show took a turn in
season three that polarized a lot of our
audience when suddenly the Cylon was
being represented as this perfect
military controlling superpower and the
humans the good guys were the ones
resorting to guerrilla tactics and
strapping themselves with c4 and blowing
up recruiting stations and everybody
went oh wow that's kind of the same
thing that's happening right now and
that's what we consider the enemy and
it's what ron was basically saying
what human beings do how far do we go in
a desperate situation to defend yourself
and those kinds of themes were risky
because some of our audience some of our
fans were were it polarized some people
they were they were like hey man you're
turning our bad guy our good guys in to
terrorists and I thought that was you
know that's the point of art is to get
is to evoke a reaction and and I think
he did that beautifully did you fellow
cast members do you have time to discuss
the more philosophical aspects between
takes we were just too busy screwing
around okay we're all with the show was
so dark you know there were so many
times when we would just be everybody
would just be miserable that we just
needed to screw around between takes
yeah we had to blow off steam grants we
didn't sit around and philosophize too
much doing hi oh okay good and first of
all I just kind of wanted to say a
little thank you in particular to you
Katie for the such a strong portrayal of
the character of Starbuck and I
personally felt that she was such an
inspirational character she was so
strong and my heel it kind it was quite
important and helped a lot of young I
just broke my heel off my shoe your
question is literally broke her shoes
you said such a strong portrayal of
Starbuck and she snapped her shoe I mean
I'm gonna fix my shoe don't worry now I
don't know no that was amazing at this
point it can't get worse yeah we could
find you a cobbler thank you um I'll get
on with the questions so you don't end
up walking out here with a lot less
clothes I just ripped my pants hold on I
started at the bit of masking tape and I
was wondering what as for you of actors
what was the most emotionally
challenging scene that you had to film
thank you by the way we can't shoot
persuade um mr. mavin um thank you by
the way I appreciate that I wish that um
I wish that I wish that I'd known at the
time actually you know I'm probably
lucky that I didn't know at the time
what we were creating with Starbuck um I
was a kid you know stop it with my shoe
stop it
I'm gonna kill him um um in the sense
that it it's um I would have been really
scared by the by the pressure of all of
that you know and probably wouldn't have
um maybe in a sense done as a convincing
of a job in a sense that you know I was
such a I was a kid and I was so insecure
and part of part of what um I think what
was so great about Starbuck is part of
what made her strong was the fact that
she was very insecure
um and I don't know I loved I loved her
and I actually learned a lot from her
you know I was 21 when I got the role so
for me um I you know I've been acting
for quite a while before that but I grew
up on the show you know I I was a kid
and yeah so that and then there was a
second part to that question that was an
actual question Oh most emotional scene
I think the most emotional scene for me
was the goodbyes between our characters
truthfully um yeah it was um it was
really heartbreaking none of that was
scripted um we weren't I wasn't supposed
to neither one of us were supposed to
speak in that scene and we were just so
overcome with emotion that we both
talked and I liked it because it it gave
them a goodbye which I don't think
Starbuck had with anyone really um so
yeah I'm gonna fix my shoe while he
answers that if anyone has a hammer that
would be really helpful
Thanks all right
yeah I would just say that whole
sequence in the last season of the show
really struck a chord with me I I had an
accident in the year 2007 I broke my
neck they incorporated that into the the
sequence that's kind of led just partly
where the story of Anders went but when
I was in that hospital bed in that scene
having just spent a few months
recovering from a broken neck in a
hospital bed with IVs hooked up that
kind of struck a deep chord because that
was a it hit a little too close to home
and then that whole sequence led up to
where Anders and Starbuck have their
last goodbyes in that tub and are we
going barefoot now we can all take our
shoes off let's all relax that I am
that's what we're doing hi so yeah that
whole sequence of that whole last part
of the last season for me I wonder if
any of the ladies in it cosplayers
have got any spare shoes that might want
to step forward maybe what size are you
I guarantee you I could go into the gift
like that where the shopping area and
find some shoes I'll be all right
my girlfriend is who my girlfriend I
mean my best friend I didn't switch
teams all of a sudden um nothing there's
anything wrong with that you know
experiment have a good time um if my
best friend is with his wife and I'm
sure that she can bring me a pair of
heels it's not going to match my outfit
but that's fine next we're gonna have to
wrap it up fairly soon there's something
that you had in common as well both of
you did guest appearances on Big Bang
Theory yes we did but I was not naked in
a bathtub Katie on the other hand he was
the third man in the tub was I there
rubba-dub-dub that would actually have
men there were two men in the tub
because I'm not a man so that's true
Meghan had you and Calais just popped up
from the bubble you may have I think
that was an original version wit
snorkels on back then yeah sorry Katie
you got to do scene with George Takei
what was that like you know um I grew up
such a massive fan of Star Trek so for
me working with jor
was like one of the coolest things I've
ever done in my entire life
and what I found really hysterical was
that we had both stolen our costumes and
no one knew until we wore them on Big
Bang Theory that we'd both stolen our
costumes excellent yeah a Michael just
to wrap it up you mentioned that there
might be something a project in the
future for that maybe two there yeah
there is a potential red project in the
future right Katie my love yes darling
he's trying to get me to admit on camera
that there is because then I might be
legally binded I would never legally
vide you know I'm actually helping
co-producer film illegally binary agency
legally binded you I am actually helping
Co produce a film that we are hoping to
shoot sometime near the end of this year
or the beginning of next year and I am
desperately on one knee trying to get my
lovely co-star Katie to join me so keep
your eyes open for something called the
last transport that's all I'm gonna say
about that it's a really cool project so
I really want to do it I'm just not
committing myself it's a lot better
offer so she's like maybe she's waiting
to see what the clothing budgets like
especially the Shay department clearly
my character is probably unlike jean
shorts and a t-shirt
trying to date that girl that like hair
we want to go to the movie she's like oh
I would but I got to wash my hair
tonight and it has a better offer as
what she's saying so I'm kind of like
getting kicked to the curb but if all
else falls through then Katie not maybe
doing a film together so keep your eyes
open keep an eye out for the last
Transpo yeah yeah that's right gonna
happen it's an awesome squeeze really
great project ladies and gentlemen I'd
like you to thank Katie and Michael
thank you very much thank you guys very
much
you